bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de cette émission
le président de l'université jean luc
baissière alerte sur l'état critique des
finances de l'établissement il manque 4
millions d'euros pour boucler le budget
2013 l'état lui financera cette année
mais réclame des coupes budgétaires
le prix du tabac ne cesse d'augmenter
conséquence une baisse des ventes et un
manque à gagner pour les buralistes
leur solution se diversifier je
papeterie cigarette électronique et
prochainement l'ouverture de comptes
paiement décryptage dans notre dossier
de la semaine et puis nous parlerons du
mois de le ss l'économie sociale et
solidaire unie c'est une initiative
nationale reprises pour la sixième année
par saint quentin en yvelines l'occasion
de parler de ce secteur avec nos invités
nous recevons laurent dumas directeur
emploi politique de la ville à la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir est
également jean marc bouillaud thibault
soir jet quant à vous responsable de la
création d'entreprise on se retrouve du
coup dans quelques minutes juste après
l'actualité économique
on en parlait dans les titres
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
proche de la cessation de paiement si ce
qu'affirme son président jean-luc
baissière dans une lettre adressée à
l'ensemble du personnel et diffusées
depuis sur internet il manquait quatre
millions d'euros à l'université sur les
dix-neuf nécessaires pour boucler le
budget 2013 l'état aurait consenti une
aide exceptionnelle en échange
l'université doit suspendre
immédiatement ses factures et de
nouveaux engagements en cause des
embauches trop nombreuses et des
investissements immobiliers coûteux pour
l'unef le syndicat étudiant la
responsabilité revient notamment au
président et à une mauvaise gestion du
budget je propose d'écouter leur
argumentaire c'est une campagne locale
premièrement il faut savoir qu'il ya
effectivement des choix budgétaires
quand même qu'ils ont été faits par
l'université et compris par le président
actuel de l'université monsieur
baissière qui a fait par exemple des
partenaires des partenariats
public-privé qui coûte extrêmement cher
à l'université et qui aujourd'hui bas
nous force à faire des coupes
budgétaires mais aussi des choix
budgétaires qui souffre est de
privilégier des masters élitiste et des
filières qui propose que qui concerne
une minorité d'étudiants et d'à côté
faire des restrictions budgétaires sur
les filières plus général et aussi les
premiers cycles licence là où il ya
besoin d'argent parce que c'est là que
j'ai qu'aujourd'hui à l'université et ce
syndicat tient actuellement une
assemblée générale à l'université pour
informer les étudiants et trouver des
solutions pour le moment le président de
l'université n'a quant à lui pas
souhaité s'exprimer
depuis maintenant six ans le mois de
novembre est dédié à l'économie sociale
et solidaire le ssd actions ont lieu
dans toute la france à saint quentin en
yvelines la première action s'est
déroulée hier une soixantaine de
personnes s'interroger sur les acteurs
du monde associatif
aujourd'hui des structures de l'urss se
sont réunis à l'université
peu de monde il n'est des organisatrices
de l'événement nous en explique l'enjeu
expliqué qu est-ce que les ss et quelles
activités elles représentent et surtout
montré que
les structures de l'ess et sont
porteuses d'emploi parce que toutes les
structures qui sont là sont des
structures employeuse en tout on a une
vingtaine de structures qui sont
présentes lupe à l'union professionnelle
artisanale ans et hier une pétition une
campagne de communication le sujet qui
fâche les hausses de tva et de charges
fiscales et sociales ils avancent le
chiffre de 54 milles défaillances
d'entreprises de moins de onze salariés
en un an vous l'avez peut-être noté les
artisans mobiliser collent des affiches
sur leur devanture ils réclament entre
autres la suppression de charge le
remplacement du cic par une baisse
directe du coût de travail ou encore
l'exclusion des autres preneurs des
activités de l'artisanat
de france met quant à lui en garde sur
le financement de la métropole du grand
paris ils craignent une hausse des
impôts pour les entreprises notamment
une hausse de 35% de leurs contributions
foncières il souhaite d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement accompagne la création de
la métropole du grand paris dans une
réduction des structures territoriales
cause selon elle des dépenses inutiles
près de 4300 entreprises sont créées
chaque année dans les yvelines pour
mieux se faire connaître et mieux
appréhender les demandes de ses patrons
une rencontre avec ses créateurs et est
organisée par la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie et les questions sont
nombreuses alors qu'une enquête
médiamétrie révèle que les sociétés
yvelinoise souffre de la crise un sujet
de catherine zula tôt et le diwan
le point commun entre tous ces chefs
d'entreprise ils sont nouveaux dans les
yvelines pour la première fois la
chambre de commerce leur a proposé une
rencontre afin de leur présenter des
outils mis à leur disposition
les questions ne manquent pas les
questions c'est par rapport aux normes
des personnes à mobilité réduite pour
les changements également pour les aides
complices à part quelques problèmes
maintenant qu'ils sont plus le niveau
des impôts les choses comme ça que je
crois que je vais faire campagne en 2012
plus de 4300 entreprises ont été créées
en majorité dans le domaine des services
une récente enquête médiamétrie pointe
du doigt des inquiétudes parmi les chefs
d'entreprise les responsables de pme
font état d'une sensible dégradation de
leur activité dans le département des
yvelines d'après les enquêtes qu'elle
était faite c'est surtout et timon le
commerce et le commerce non alimentaire
en particulier qui souffrent aussi les
autres entreprises qui ont pas prévu ni
d'investir ni de recruter et je pense qu
on est dans une période un petit peu
compliqué actuellement il y en a besoin
justement d'accompagner les entreprises
on est là pour apporter peut-être des
solutions qui auquel il ne pense pas des
nouveaux outils dead qui passe par un
rapprochement géographique les yvelines
sont maintenant découpé en cinq zones et
un élu et un conseiller sont affectés à
chaque partie du territoire mais ce
n'est pas tout nous réfléchissons
beaucoup sur un certain nombre de
caution
on essaie d'être des idées sur les plans
de revitalisation
on espère pouvoir trouver des solutions
sur les prêts
aux entreprises qui ont besoin d'emprunt
on a plusieurs pistes actuellement
mérite un petit peu tôt pour en parler
des soutiens qui sont un véritable enjeu
car comme l'affirment girard bacheliers
lui-même chef d'entreprise le plus
difficile n'est pas de créer sa société
mais de la faire évoluer une prochaine
soirée bienvenue en yvelines sera
organisé en février 2014
la quinzaine de l'artisanat se déroula
plaisir jusqu'au 16 novembre
on en parlait dans une précédente file
echo pardon pendant cette période onze
artisans ont ouvert les portes de leur
atelier et parmi eux une femme élise
t'installes et ébéniste d'origine belge
elle est installée dans la commune
depuis deux ans rencontre un reportage
de catherine mulato et patrick jacques
de dixmude
dans cet atelier on entend surtout le
bruit des marteaux eli stone stall et
ébénistes et le secret d'un beau produit
tiendrait selon elle dans l'ajustement
des clous attention à bien clouer droit
à ne pas faire craquer le bois et a bien
aligné les morceaux entre
son atelier a ouvert ses portes à
l'occasion de la quinzaine de
l'artisanat elise a été formé en
belgique
après son diplôme elle a travaillé cinq
ans auprès de son père lui-même ébéniste
ce qui plaît le plus c'est de sortir du
bois brut et le transformer
est arrivé de cannes mais en même temps
j'aime beaucoup aussi redonner vie à des
meubles qui qui ont été alignées ou
délaissés pendant un certain nombre
d'années qu'ils retrouvent leur beauté
d'antan
elise utilise des techniques modernes
les garde aussi un oeil sur les produits
anciens à l'exemple des cols
ça se présente sous forme de petites
perles comme ça
donc on mélange ça et on chausse dans un
bain-marie c'est à dire on ne fait pas
ça ça se chauffe contrairement au col
monnaire sont déjà très pâle visage col
de l'apa ou de poisson reconnus pour
leur réversible et permettra ainsi de
défaire ce qui vient d'être ajustés jeu
comme une ébénistes du 21e siècle donc
j'utilise les techniques modernes tout
en utilisant savoir-faire de des anciens
gens découvrent et encore parce que j'en
apprends tous les jours et chaque cas
chaque meuble je ne connais pas encore
tous donc des fois je dois me renseigner
sur les techniques anciennes c'est ça
qui est très intéressant à défaut on
peut appliquer des choses anciennes à
des créations justement s'exprimer au
site elise est installé à plaisir depuis
deux ans
aujourd'hui ont célébré la première
pierre de l'immeuble berlioz en 2015 cet
immeuble accueillera le laboratoire
pharmaceutique américain baxter pour le
moment son siège social est à maurepas
une opération immobilière pour
l'entreprise qui passera de locataires
et propriétaires 400 salariés
s'installeront dans ses nouveaux locaux
et puis une bonne nouvelle pour les
éleveurs un atelier de découpe devrait
ouvrir l'année prochaine à rambouillet
un projet de 500 mille euros financés
par la communauté de communes des
plaines et forêts d'evelyne à la région
et l'état depuis quelques mois il
n'existait plus aucune structure en ile
de france le dernier abattoir à nogent
le rotrou a fermé en février dernier et
on passe maintenant à l'entretien
et avec nos invités nous allons parler
de le ss l'économie sociale et solidaire
nous recevons laurent dumas donc
directeur emploi politique de la ville à
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et jean marc
bodiot ti vous êtes responsable de la
création et du développement des
entreprises bonsoir à tous les deux
alors donc depuis six ans novembre
représente le mois de l'ess est un
événement national qui est repris à
saint quentin en yvelines depuis sa
création différentes animations ont lieu
pour faire connaître ce secteur alors
justement l'économie sociale et
solidaire en quelques mots qu'est ce que
c'est concrètement ornella peut-être
alors l'économie sociale et solidaire
donc c'est un ensemble assez hétéroclite
s est multiforme de structures d'acteurs
économiques qui s'engagent sur un
certain nombre de principes le principe
de la lucrativité limitée le principe de
l'utilité sociale et le principe de la
gouvernance démocratique alors quelques
exemples alors sur notre territoire et
sont relativement nombreux puisqu'on a à
près de 330 sucre structures qui sont
dans l'économie sociale et solidaire et
on retrouve aussi bien des associations
que des mutuelles comme la mgen par
exemple ou bien des établissements
bancaires et on trouve également des
coopératives dans une moindre mesure et
on retrouve également des fondations
comme le club fasse par exemple le club
d'entreprises très pendant ce mois de ss
il ya eu un village d'acteurs de le ss
qui était organisée aujourd'hui à
l'université de 50 ans ni ville mercredi
prochain au jardin partagé ouvrira ses
portes à trappes et le 27 novembre donc
je remarque borghetti vous allez donner
rendez vous aux entrepreneurs de quoi
sera-t-il question l'idée c'est
d'organiser un atelier sur
l'entrepreneuriat dans l'économie
sociale et solidaire avec les différents
partenaires qui nous relie au sein de la
maison de l'entreprise et qui permettra
à des créateurs d'entreprise de
favoriser l'initiative sur le s est en
sueur comme orienté son projet vers le
ss sur des informations concrètes et
pratiques sur le statut juridique sur
les 10 positif financiers qui peuvent
accompagner cette démarche il faut
s'inscrire il ya combien de places alors
les places sont limitées 15 15 places
maximum on a déjà des premiers retours
des premières inscriptions donc
inscrivez vous vite au sein de la maison
de l'entreprise sur le site de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ou par
téléphone 09 30 51 30 message est passé
alors une étude a été réalisée récemment
sur le ss à 50 ans ni ville ce qu'il en
ressort c'est quand équivalent
temps-plein la part des salariés n'est
que de 4,2 pour cent contre 6,6 en
ile-de-france et 9,7 en france donc
comment expliquer ce faible taux
finalement vous disais que j'avais pas
mal d'entreprises pas de structure
pardon alors effectivement on a 330
structure on a près de 4700 emplois sur
les 108 mille emplois qui sont recensés
à saint quentin en yvelines alors c'est
une faiblesse qui et j'allais dire toute
relative et qui tient essentiellement à
la nature du tissu économique de saint
quentin en yvelines avec notamment la
prééminence de grands groupes je pense
notamment à renault ou bien à sodexo la
coff médéric ou bouygues il faut savoir
qu'un pour cent des entreprises
représentent 50% des salariés à saint
quentin en yvelines donc c'est cette
prééminence des grands groupes en fait
tu as tendance à marginaliser en fait
les acteurs de ss et notamment les
acteurs du champ associatif il n'en
reste pas moins que c'est un secteur qui
est extrêmement dynamique avec près de
4700 emploi donc c'est un ensemble un
sous-ensemble de l'économie
résidentielle et qui est marquée par une
par une très grande hétérogénéité
des aspects multiformes puisqu'on trouve
aussi bien des mutuelles je le disais
tout à l'heure le retrouve également
artisans du monde on trouve donc des
acteurs du commerce équitable
on trouve le secteur de l'insertion par
l'activité économique avec des
entreprises d'insertion qui ont pour
objectif d'accueillir des salariés qui
sont en difficultés d'insertion sur le
marché du travail alors vous parlez de
grande diversité pourtant dans les
chiffres encore une fois il ya peu
d'entreprises beaucoup d'associations
elles sont 81% sur les avancements des
structures donc avant de vous faire
réagir là-dessus je vous propose déjà
d'écouter une responsable graine qui
participent à l'organisation de ce mois
de l'urss à saint quentin en yvelines
dont je suis justement pardon posé la
question en effet pas mal d'associations
après et peu de coopérative après c'est
aussi culturel c'est-à-dire que
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et une ville
nouvelle donc c'est à dire c'est
beaucoup de goût de famille donc pas mal
d'associations de loisirs qui ont été
créés pour l'instant peu d'entreprises
coopératives mais avoir peut-être avec
les évolutions au niveau législatif
peut-être que ce sera une voilà une
impulsion ça amènerait une impulsion sur
le territoire
sur le côté les gestations on en
reparlera tout à l'heure c'est vous
l'expliquer de la même façon une
explication culturel alors effectivement
historiquement il ya une densité des vie
associative à saint quentin en yvelines
qui est peut-être plus importantes mais
on sait que c'est une caractéristique
également de toutes les villes nouvelles
de la région ile de france et cette
densité de la vie associative est
fortement accompagné par les
collectivités par les communes notamment
et par la communauté d'agglomération
alors à noter quand même qu'on a un
secteur de l'activité qui est peut-être
plus représenter que d'autres sans être
majoritaire c'est celui de la culture
des arts des loisirs c'est un secteur
qui est extrêmement important à saint
quentin en yvelines et puis la vie
sportive bien évidemment qui est
extrêmement développé et intimes du coup
la majorité des activités de le ss ici
alors autre caractéristique beaucoup de
femmes 66 % pour une fois on dépasse la
variété et puis pour beaucoup des
personnes âgées il y en à 15,2 pour cent
qui partiront à la retraite en 2020
alors généralement donc c'est des
membres d'associations on sait qu'il ya
aussi une perte du bénévolat est ce que
finalement ce n'est pas un point positif
est ce que ça va finalement laissé un
petit peu d'air pour des créations
d'emplois pour des projets pour des
jeunes entrepreneurs jean marie goretti
oui je pense concrètement qu'aujourd'hui
il ya une volonté aussi des personnes de
porter des projets verts cette économie
sociale et solidaire pour
redéfinir aussi le ssc l'homme au centre
du projet c'est vrai que les notions de
rentabilité
ne sont pas forcément primordial
comparer une économie d'activité
économique le classique et
traditionnelle cela dit elle répondent
quand même à des normes comptables
financières bien évidemment donc oui il
ya aussi une volonté de de lancer ce
type de projet aussi nous au sein de la
maison de l'entreprise de les
accompagner on parlait d' économie
résidentielle de personnes de services
par exemple à la personne sur des
personnes âgées des personnes
handicapées des personnes publiques plus
fragiles aujourd'hui crée des emplois ça
aussi c'est important on accompagne
céder ses activités liées à l'économie
sociale et solidaire créatrice d'emplois
on parle aussi différents types de
projets récemment du transport adapté
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite
donc qui permet aussi quelque part de
gagner en proximité de favoriser les
déplacements sur tous les enjeux qui
peuvent être liés aussi à la transports
et mobilité donc oui il ya un vrai essor
aujourd'hui sur ses lignes dynamiques
qu'on essaye d'accompagner sur le
territoire de 51,10 là pour l'instant au
niveau de la france a représenté 10% du
pib 10 % des emplois
est-ce que du coup à terme ça pourrait
prendre finalement me caser la majorité
des entreprises
l'avenir nous le dira si
l'ensemble des territoires sont à même
de développer des initiatives favoriser
la création d'activités les pérenniser
aussi
par des dispositifs
de financement d'accompagnement
évidemment ce chiffre ne peut que
progresser justement il ya une dernière
question sur la loi un monde qui a été
voté au sénat qui doit passer à
l'assemblée nationale est ce qu'elle
peut apporter justement un plus oui
effectivement c'est un projet de loi qui
sera votée par l'assemblée nationale au
mois de janvier et qui devrait
accompagner ce secteur en tout cas le
reconnaître davantage
incité des porteurs de projets à passer
à l'acte en allant notamment visiter mon
collègue à la maison de l'entreprise
donc ça c'est un point important et puis
c'est aussi une loi qui va permettre de
développer des moyens financiers
nouveaux des outils financiers nouveaux
qui seront à la disposition des acteurs
de l'ess
notamment par exemple à la banque
publique d'investissement qui qui
financera en partie je vous remercie
tous les deux d'avoir été présent sur
notre plateau merci merci à vous et puis
on passe au dossier de la semaine
peut-on encore considérer les buralistes
comme de simples vendeurs de tabac si
cela reste leur activité principale il
se diversifie d'année en année la hausse
du prix du tabac et la baisse des ventes
les pousse à trouver d'autres sources de
revenus parfois des plus originales
décryptage avec ce reportage réalisé
avec elodie moines jacques parent dont
jonathan vilma et patrick jacques de
dixmude
dont ce bureau de tabac de saint cyr
l'école on trouve du tabac mais aussi
des jeux à gratter des revues des cartes
postales des bonbons des chaussettes ou
encore des bijoux yvan est buraliste
depuis huit ans pour augmenter son
chiffre d'affaires une seule solution la
diversification chaque année on essaie
d'apporter une autre idée pour faire
venir d'autres personnes dans ma grain
un des arguments avancés la hausse du
prix du tabac dernière augmentation en
date plus 20 centimes sur le paquet de
cigarettes le 15 juillet dernier 40 sur
le paquet de tabac à rouler depuis le
début de l'année les ventes ont baissé
de 9% en france selon la confédération
des buralistes
la plus forte baisse depuis 2005 à cette
date le paquet de cigarettes le plus
vendu coûté 5 euros il vaut aujourd'hui
6 euros 80 ça commence à être un produit
de luxe comme fumer un cigare
je sais pas à chaque fois là chaque
augmentation le volume metz a été
compensée en partie par l'augmentation
du prix depuis la dernière
l'augmentation du coût ne compense pas
la perte en volume même son de cloche
pour ce buraliste verrier roi où il y
amar pris 7 en scène il y à 7 ans il
porte aujourd'hui de multiples
casquettes et si libraire la caf petits
commerces comme les objets tout faire
avant on faisait vraiment plus du tabac
ou quand nous est cher un peu de bar un
peu de journaux un peu un peu tout et
même cigarette électronique l'obligé
est-ce que ça c'est donc sans simple
contraire de ce qu'on vend maintenant
mais bon on l'obligé d'enfer les
cigarettes électroniques un marché en
vogue elles séduisent de plus en plus de
fumeurs ils seraient entre 500 mille et
un million d'adeptes de cette
alternative au tabac depuis l'ouverture
du premier point de vente début 2010
plus de 150 boutiques spécialisées se
sont créés un chiffre qui devrait
doubler d'ici à la fin de l'année
de véritables concurrents pour les
buralistes qui réclament l'exclusivité
des ventes mais pour les vendeurs 10
cigarettes leurs enseignes ont toute
légitimité on a un magasin de chaussures
à côté dans notre magasin de chaussures
ce qu'on peut dire que un des magasins
de chaussures fait de la concurrence
déloyale à l'autre non je pense pas y en
a un qui vont des chaussures de ville
l'autre qui vont des baskets voilà on
est sur des produits qui sont
complètement différents et si on peut
parler de concurrence effectivement
peut-être mais en tout cas elle est
certainement pas déloyale au 1er janvier
le tabac enregistrera une nouvelle
hausse un paquet de cigarettes
classiques coûtera alors 7 euros 10
cette augmentation des prix la 3e en 15
mois compenserez la hausse de la tva de
19,6 à 20% et celle de la part revenant
aux buralistes de 8,6 à 8,7 pour cent
brut par paquet de quoi gonfler les
ventes des cigarettes électroniques
qu'effectivement ça va certainement nous
amener une vague de clients
le fait du fait qu'ils alignent une
augmentation du prix du tabac mais je
pense pas que ce soit c'est pas le leit
motiv principal de nos clients c'est pas
forcément l'argent c'est surtout le
c'est surtout la santé les buralistes
compte récupérer une partie du marché le
choix est désormais surtout leurs étals
cigarette classique ou électronique et
pour compenser un peu plus leur manque à
gagner les buralistes s'ouvre un nouveau
marché le marché bancaire à partir du
1er janvier ils proposeront à leurs
clients d'ouvrir en moins de dix minutes
un compte unique elles se comptent
comprendra un relevé d'identité bancaire
permettant virements et paiement et une
carte de paiement mastercard
mais à la différence des établissements
bancaires
les marchands de tabac et leurs
partenaires la financière des paiements
électroniques ne feront pas de crédit il
ne prêteront pas d'argent la
confédération des buralistes à
l'initiative du projet attend cent mille
clients 2014 pour ouvrir ce compte une
simple carte d'identité un numéro de
téléphone suffisent l'accueil semble
mitigé on retire la ja ici ici ça c'est
pas un moment ça allait chercher
cigarettes ont tout le temps de l'argent
je c'est vrai c'est pratiquement la
banque suis ni pour ni contre
c'est un autre moyen de paiement
mais alors qu'il est sécurisé dès lors
qu que ça n'en mène pas de difficultés
majeures pour l'utilisateur aucun aucun
a priori les associations de
consommateurs elles aussi ne sont pas
forcément d'accord l'ufc que choisir
applaudi la création d'un compte
bancaire low cost mais la fox semble
sceptique je suis pas sur moi au final
que le consommateur s'y retrouve on a un
mélange des genres qui est en train de
se faire et puis là c'est quelque chose
d'artificiel on n'a pas fait ça pour le
consommateur on a fait ça en réalité
pour compenser un manque à gagner
financier des buralistes est ce que
bientôt les banques pour aussi compenser
le manque à gagner vous vendre des
cigarettes je ne suis pas sûr en premier
client visé les interdits bancaires et
les personnes résidant en milieu rural
mais ce sera aux buralistes de décider
s'ils proposent ou non ces cons de
nickel la fédération des paiements
électroniques devra alors valider leur
candidature et les formes et contre le
blanchiment et le financement du
terrorisme
le contrôle une des critiques émises
contre ce système on enlèvera raison
broker nous avons dans l'essonne
5à des contrôleurs par réseau bancaire
qui contrôle les dossiers donc c'est
vrai que il faut voir quels sont les
moyens qui seront mis en amont et en
aval pour contrôler des buralistes qui
ne sont pas des banques est par essence
et qui n'auront une formation que très à
l'aise les dépôts d'argent resteront
tout de même limitée 250 euros maximum
en une fois et 750 euros au total par
mois le coût 20 euros par an auxquels
s'ajouteront des frais de retrait 50
centimes chez un buraliste 1 euros dans
un distributeur ainsi qu une commission
de 2 euros sur les dépôts des frais
partiellement perçue par les buralistes
d'après ce qu'a dit on va gagner sur une
ouverture de compte 3 euros mais bon ce
qui est ce qui est important c'est de
augmenté de flux dans les établissements
c'est pas le tabac ont gagné pas
énormément sur un paquet de cigarettes
mais ce qu'il ya c'est que c'est le
le passage l'union de passage des gens
viennent acheter un paquet de cigarettes
pour faire un loto pour mac a fait et
c'est ça en fait qu'on ait des gens qui
est du gagne-petit c'est chaque client
ne ramène un peu quelque chose mais si
ce client devient pu tous les jours on
perd pas que sur les cigarettes on perd
sur l'ensemble de nos activités il
faudra attendre l'année prochaine pour
connaître le succès de ses comptes
nickel mais une chose est sûre la
diversification des activités le
buraliste n'est pas prête de s'arrêter
même si la vente de cigarettes reste
encore aujourd'hui la plus rentable
et c'est la fin de ce fil est qu merci
de nous avoir suivis je vous donne
rendez vous la semaine prochaine à très
bientôt bonne soirée